[Music]
this video is very special because we
are going to interview a successful
entrepreneur who not only started and
runs her own businesses successfully but
actually went back to school to pursue
her passion of serving others through
nursing she's incredibly courageous and
persistent
let's meet Tammy Williams all right
Tammy well welcome to our channel here
well thank you it's my pleasure to be
here so we have some questions for you
um the first question is what success
meant to you when you are 20 and what
does it mean to you now well I've given
it some thought as far as how life has
changed simple because as you know I met
a new station of life I'm going from
work to retirement and what is a
successful retirement mean so looking
back success was quite different as a 20
year old because I let society dictate
or what I thought success was you know
when you're in your 20s
everybody encourages you to have home
and family and kids and cars and and all
that and it was very important to me at
that point
now as I've matured and gotten a little
bit older I came to realize that you
have to add in some soul satisfaction
and soul satisfaction comes from doing
what is your colleague in
that God wants you to be on so as I got
a little bit older I defined it
differently now what I consider
successful is being on the right path
that God created for me and reaching my
colony and going back to nursing was
that for me yeah after building a
business and loving the business and
knowing that that was what was right for
me at that time going back to nursing
was the calling for what I call the
second half of my life and now I'm
really excited to see where I will go in
the future with this retirement
so you think service is a big part of
success absolutely
I'm not going to say I wasn't serving at
20 but at 20 society more guided what I
thought success was and then as I got
into my 30s and 40s I realized that
success was really what God had designed
for me and I let him guide what I deemed
is successful and so now that I'm
looking into retirement
it's all about what he wants in his will
because that's what genuinely will make
me happy ultimately is to do what he's
created for my future the second
question is what advice do you have for
millenials who want to be successful mmm
advice um I think it comes in a couple
of stages first off you've got to have a
good relationship with God because some
people will say oh follow your heart
well there's a lot of things that my
heart said I wanted to do that weren't
necessarily going to earn me enough
money to eat on and so getting in
alignment with what God has in plan for
you is going to be the best path the
second thing that I strongly encourage
is to learn how to manage your money if
you don't know how to manage your money
[Music]
it's going to manage you and when money
is the driver it leads you to make
decisions that you probably wouldn't
normally make if it weren't so so
important and unfortunately money does
make the world go around money is
something we have to learn how to deal
with and manage correctly and with you
know ultimately God leading the show but
us having to live in society where money
is everything we have to manage our
money
I think the the third thing to success
is a support system if you don't have a
good support system it makes life a very
challenging because then too many other
factors rock your boat so a good support
system learning how to manage your money
and then a good prayer life and
relationship with God I think those are
the sleep gun the sir you can't go this
next question why do you think that
failure is important for personal growth
um
there's not a word that I use very often
but it's definitely a part of life and I
saw a good saying the other day it said
that calm waters never make a refined
sailor and it's true without failures
you can't hone who you are the skills
that you have and your thinking without
the rough times without making mistakes
without troubled waters you'll you'll
never be master of your ship and I think
it's an important part I think the only
real failure in life is never trying to
do it yeah it's the one thing that we've
mentioned on this channel is failure
it's really only an opportunity for
improvement oh and it goes along with
them oh absolutely
I can't you know I've failed far more
than I've succeeded but in the end it
always comes out well and I there was a
thing that I began to think actually a
friend shared it with me that was very
important that I kind of cleaned - when
I think about failure and he often he
said to me if
money and death are two factors in
failure if you if you have enough money
unit you can fix all things and as long
as it's not dead its revival yeah so
with those two thoughts put together
there's nothing that couldn't be fixed
or repair or recover and so at that
point it kind of freed me to try more
things and kind of get out of my comfort
zone yeah because I feared failure there
left less you know I could call in a
professional to fix what I broke if I
made it worse or I could I could go and
earn more money to fix or to buy or to
repair or replace what what I couldn't
fix oh I became less fearful of failure
when I realized oh if money can fix it
in its
let's give it a try look giving it a try
that's the key when starting out how did
you handle it sucked out self-doubt was
that I still struggle with that
sometimes thank you
but going back to my previous answer
once I realize that it's okay to throw
it in the trash and start again
yeah or it's okay to call in that expert
to fix what you you thought you couldn't
it could it's okay to mess up yeah it's
okay once you gave yourself permission
to not do it perfectly or to always know
everything it kind of frees you and I
also going back to an earlier answer to
I have a great support system if I think
I'm a little bit off or I come up with
this crazy idea I definitely have my
church friends my nursing friends my
business friends my mommy friends I'll
give one of them a call i phone a friend
so when I'm feeling doubt or fearful in
not wanting on a productive position for
it
great I'll bake I love the great piece
of advice this one I think is very
important how do you handle people that
are dream brochures oh um I've always
said and I believe this to my heart that
if you understand understanding leads to
compassion and compassion to love and
ultimately we are called to love
everyone and it's very hard to love the
crazy makers in your life
and so what I attempt to do with with
dream crushers is and in my experience
I've found that they come from three
different places I try to understand why
three pressures and it's been my
experience that I've come across three
three types of or three people motivated
to be dream pressures one of them is
there are some people they're just never
gonna be pleasant to be around yet
they're often negative they're often
what I used to call a debbie downer
they just throws down on negative many
negative nancies exactly and so those
people you can't fix you can just love
them and try to to keep that that
comfort zone of you around them and
don't let them invade your space or
invade your mind of being negative then
you have the other ones that are kind of
they themselves feel unworthy of of
having God's best and so they don't
think you're worthy of it either or they
don't want you to be worthy of it they
feel like oh gods only got so many
mansions to hand out so you shouldn't
should get one either because I can't
get one and so because they feel
unworthy they want you to feel unworthy
as well and then you have the one the
people I think that are kind of jealous
and they want to dampen your spirit and
dampen your desires and your dreams
because it makes them feel better that
they're not chasing their own because
they want the highest building by
tearing down your building exactly and
so once I kind of in right or wrong it's
kind of how I've learned to deal with it
is once I've kind of put them in that
category when they come at me with their
negativeness or they come at me with
their derogative comments you know I
just think oh well you know I'm sorry
that you don't feel worthy or I'm sorry
that you're jealous it's not that I'm
trying to be not making it personal yeah
not about you exactly and it's not that
I'm placing blame on them but it's just
that I I can understand where they're
coming from and thus I can have
compassion
and even bring them into my prayer
sometimes and say you know they really
God they really hurt me with that that
statement or they discouraged me but I
understand it comes from a place of envy
or a place of unworthiness in their own
life and just let them know that they
are loved and cared for as well so
that's kind of how I deal with it up
right or wrong well that's a great piece
of advice I thank you so much for
joining us and for sharing your wisdom
it's it's an honor I the first guest so
there you have it guys some wonderful
advice from a successful entrepreneur
from a faith-based perspective if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe so you
won't miss out on my weekly videos thank
you so much for watching bye